يخشى الخيانه ويلجا اليها كحجه في كثير من
الاحيان لكن اكثر ما يخيف النظام الان
يعرف عنه الكثير الجيل زد وراء توجيه
وادامه موجه الاحتجاجات الاخيره وهي التي
لم يتداركها مثل ما فعل في انتفاضه كبرى
سيطره عليها في الاعوام الخمسه الماضيه
الشجاعه والمثابره التي يتحلى بهما هؤلاء
اكبر من طاقه السلطات على الاستيعاب ابناء
العالم الافتراضي كما يطلق عليهم النظام
هم ولدوا حول مطلع الالفيه واصبحوا الان
اموراهقين وشبابا بل اكثر من ذلكم نحو 18
مليون من اصل 90 مليون ايرانيين بحسب مركز
الاحصاء الرسمي يتبعهم اربعه 24 مليون
تقريبا تبلغ اعمارهم 25 عاما وحتى 39
وكثيرا من المطالب اتقاطع بين لكن النظام
وجود نوعا من الغدر في رغبه الجلده في
التعاطي مع العالم الخارجي غير انهم ليسوا
وحدهم فارباط 84% من الايرانيين باتوا
يتمتعون بامكانيات الوصول الى الانترنت
بحلول عام 2020 الفرق هو ان الجسد صوته
اعلى وذاكرته لا تحمل امجاد ثوره الخميني
والخوف منها بل هي مثقله بازمات اقتصاديه
سياسيه قمع وتكميم للافواه وازكاه
للموسيقى والفن والكل ما هو لا يتناسب مع
صوره النظام الانعزال الرافده للاخر